Marvel Comics eternals are an ancient
cosmic rays who live on Saturn's moon
Titan
if Marvel Studios embraces all the
cosmos spanning wonder of the group's
comic book appearances in the upcoming
Eternals movie viewers have some
Technicolor treats in store here's the
lowdown on the Eternals the Eternals
were created by comics legend Jack Kirby
in 1976 they're an ancient race of super
beings have long protected earth from
evil specifically the role of the
treacherous deviants the original
eternal series holds a meticulously
plotted tale and was created with an
ending in mind unfortunately Kirby never
reached his intended finale the Eternals
was axed at issue 19 before kirby had a
chance to wrap up all of the existing
plot threads it lingered and finished
for a while and so writers Roy Thomas
and Mark Grunwald used a storyline that
ended with Thor issue 301 to wrap up the
tale of the Eternals cosmic crusade
we're glad the story ended up resolved
but we'll always be wondering what it
could have looked like if Kirby had a
chance to finish the series as he
intended well their name was on the
cover the Eternals arguably weren't the
breakout stars of their own book that
was the Celestials the space gods that
created the Eternals the deviants and it
turns out pretty much all sentient life
in the Marvel Universe the Celestials
were an example of Kirby building on an
idea had explored in other comics they
were a step past Galactus who he and
Stanek created in Fantastic Four a
massive humanoid that was essentially a
living force of nature with ties to the
origins of the universe even their
designs were similar cladding Kirby's
trademark elaborate armor but while
Galactus had a recognizable human face
the Celestials were completely covered
by their armor making them far more
unknowable the Celestials would have
fine by the ongoing life creation
experiments that they've been tinkering
with for billions of years with names
that indicated the function the memnon
the gatherer for example was charged
with acquiring samples of life from
across the universe era sham the church
would determine whether a planet's
population would live or die once the
experimented when its course and exit
are the exterminator well you can guess
his job while characters like Icarus
have often been overlooked the
Celestials were woven into the fabric of
the Marvel Universe with connections to
everything from the x-men to the
Infinity stones the Avengers have even
set up a headquarters in a building made
from the body of a long-dead celestial
you can't create a team of superheroes
of
improper antagonists there must always
be a Loki per every Thor and Kirby knew
this couldn't well one approach in the
Eternals so he gave them the deviance
when the Celestials created the Eternals
they also created the deviance a
horrifying race of creatures are
physically the opposite of the beautiful
humanoid Eternals the two species are
caught in a constant war between one
another with the deviants forming a sort
of natural opposition no deviant
mutation is repeated in their species to
each physical anomaly or superpower is
unique to the deviant who possesses it
they are effectively mutations of the
Eternals thousands of years ago the
deviants resided on earth and conquered
much of early humanity the Eternals
ended their reign though deviant still
live on earth to this day and crash with
eternals regularly Kirby's stories were
often more inspired by timeless literary
classics than they were by other comics
his Thor stories a very much
Shakespearean while the Fantastic Four
draws heavily from sci-fi literature and
classic monster movies it only makes
sense that he'd carry that ethos into
creating the Eternals Kirby is on the
record as naming two novels as primary
influences on the series the first two
sci-fi master arthur c clarke childhoods
end this novel in particular influenced
Kirby's interpretation of the Celestials
as well as a uni mind a massively
powerful composite of several Eternals
he also drew heavily from Erich von
Daniken's chart of the Gods a nonfiction
book that posits the idea of alien guts
it's proof that the best way to tell
great stories is a draw inspiration from
a wealth of sources not just a medium or
genre in which you work it makes sense
of the filmmakers behind the MCU would
it bring the Eternals into play they
already have a tie to the world at this
point at journals such as Star Fox
Cersei and McCrory can already be easily
introduced to the world to their
families presence in the MCU in the form
of the mad Titan himself Thanos
in palaces perhaps the most famous of
the Eternals while he wasn't introduced
in the original kirby series jim Starlin
the creator of Thanos designed him as an
extension of their world Thanos is a
deviant child of an eternal mother and
father are being born into a world that
instantly rejected him his mother was so
disgusted with him from birth that she
tried to kill him as a child his
traumatic childhood only furthered his
fascination with death which eventually
led to him becoming the mad Titan while
it's very rarely associated with the
eternal directly these days he's very
much a product of their society the
eternal relationship with their creators
the Celestials is a bit turbulent if at
times found themselves on opposing sides
of the battlefield the Celestials being
giant omnipotent immortal beings are
pretty hard to take on in battle so it
makes sense that and what may be the
most famous occasion during which the
two races came to blows the Eternals
didn't go out alone who better to take
on the Eternals and another race of gods
the Eternals offer their aid to the
forces of Asgard when the two sides
found themselves out to the Celestials
the Eternals form the unis mind which is
kind of like an eternal Megazord
while Odin possessed the destroyer armor
and enlarged it to be the size of the
Celestials kind of like Ultraman it
might not get the recognition the
Avengers and x-men do whenever they join
forces but we think is one of the cooler
moments in the history of the Eternals a
bunch of giant mega powerful space gods
and robots duking it out is a pretty
solid story as far as we're concerned
taro said his brother starfox just about
as polar-opposite as they could be
Thanos is a massive purple death
worshiping supervillain starfox on the
other hand is a conventionally
attractive ladies man who typically
fights on the side of good his hair is
always perfect
that being said starfox as far from
squeaky-clean his rather appropriate
real name as a Ross the same name as the
Greek god of love and his super power
allows him to manipulate emotions
especially romantic ones which has
occasionally got him into legal trouble
he specifically puts on trial for
harassment after a married woman claimed
to use his powers to seduce her his
lawyer in the case is none other than
Jennifer Walters better known as
she-hulk
it's a story that could be taken as a
one though joke but instead becomes a
genuinely compelling look into the
ethics of Star Fox's powers it comes to
light that he's used them to not only
make people attracted to him but to
influence the feelings of others he's
responsible for Walter's marriage
John Jameson and as briefly convinced
that he triggered Thanos's initial
infatuation with death the story ends
with starfox agreeing to have his powers
shut down so that he won't be able to
hurt anyone else with them
there's something about SuperSpeed that
just feels right it's not too
complicated it doesn't make the user
never delete powerful it's perhaps the
most perfect superpower as such it makes
sense that there are so many comic book
superheroes and villains that run really
fast Marvel alone has Quicksilver
Whizzer and among others Macari a member
of the Eternals family but even he's not
the fastest out there an issue of quasar
written by Mark Grunwald features a
ground race between all of the
speedsters in the marvel universe
including McCrory the one that comes out
on top however isn't a character we've
seen before
he's an amnesiac from a different
universe even he doesn't remember his
real name though he seems to recall it
being something like buried alien this
issue came out just after DC Comics the
flash also known as Barry Allen had
perished in crisis on Infinite Earths
Grunwald very clearly introduced buried
alien as an homage to the character the
Eternals generally keep to themselves
their stories are often pretty contained
and don't bleed out into the rest of the
Marvel Universe but there are exceptions
to every role and the eternal known as
Cersei is one of them
Cersei is pretty largely integrated into
the world of Marvel she can cast
illusions has super-strength and has the
ability to teleport Cersei was for a
time even a member of the Avengers she
joined at the invitation of none other
than Captain America her decision to
join the team at the time it's just as
motivated by her desire to do good as it
is by her infatuation with the star
spangled avenger which is harbored for
quite some time her tenure on the team
came to a close in the 1990s she has
since aided the team on occasion and
while she's yet to properly woo cap
we're sure she's not done trying
Ultron has been a thorn in the side of
the heroes of the Marvel Universe for
decades fueled by an abject hatred of
humanity the evil robots sole mission is
the extermination of humanity so what
happens when Ultron is introduced the
power of love in the graphic novel rage
of Ultron we see what happens when
starfox emotion manipulation powers meet
the robot menace in the stories finale
Ultron and his creator Hank Pym have
merged into a singular being prepared to
wipe out humanity once and for all
starfox is able to defeat them by using
his powers to introduce love into the
equation being
takes Ultron and Hank back to the moment
that robot was activated and makes both
of them reevaluate it recognizing their
love for each other as a sort of father
and son I wanted to show you I don't
have anyone else
Ultron's introduction to love is enough
to get him to back off and to banish
himself into the depths of space Star
Fox's powers may make him a weird creep
sometimes but they've also managed to
save the world at least once when it was
announced in April 2018 at CERN oz was
one of the more surprising entries in
phase four of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but there was a hint of what
was to come
all the way back in 2014 with a brief
cameo in another surprising Marvel movie
in guardians of the galaxy when the
collector is explaining the Infinity
stones we get an unmistakable glimpse of
a celestial using the Power Stone to
eradicate the population of some
unfortunate planets nowhere is the
severed head of a celestial and the ego
identifies himself as a celestial in
guardians volume 2 I'm what's called a
celestial sweetheart
celestial like a god small geez five
years after that first glimpse of the
eons long saga of eternal deviance and
Celestials
we finally got a better idea of what we
can expect when Eternals hits the screen
in 2020 a Marvel's panel at San Diego
comic-con fans were introduced to the
main cast
[Applause]
interestingly enough while the movie was
originally billed as focusing on Icarus
and Cersei the latter character was
absent from the announcement instead we
were introduced to richard madden best
known as Robb Stark from Game of Thrones
as Icarus Angelina Jolie escena Salma
Hayek as a jack
stand-up comedian and Academy Award
nominated screenwriter Kumail Nanjiani
as Kingo former Miss deaf America and
Walking Dead actress Loren Riddler
phasma Cory
Atlanta's Brian Tyree Henry as Fastow's
Korean megastar Don Lee as Gilgamesh and
Lea McHugh sprites as for the plots no
details have been released just yet but
if the Celestials are out there
obliterating planets someone should
probably deal with that check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about Marvel
superheroes are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and to the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]